compound interest is basically the idea
that let's say if you're earning 10 a
year the first year you make 10 and you
end up with let's say you got a dollar
you invested you end up with a dollar
ten for the next year you end up with a
dollar twenty one and the next year you
end up with a dollar three and two or
three so it keeps adding on itself in
such a way that if you're compounding at
30 a year for 30 years you don't just
end up with you know 10 or 20 times your
money you end up with thousands of times
your money so a compound interest is a
very powerful concept the compound
interest applies to more than just
compounding Capital compounding business
relationships is very important
look at some of the top roles in society
like why does someone get to be a CEO of
a public company or be on the board of a
public company or why does someone get
to be a banker who's managing a billion
dollars is because people trust them and
they trust them because the relationship
in which they've worked the work they've
done it's kind of compounded they've
stuck with the business and they've
shown themselves in a visible and
accountable way to be high integrity
people